cloverfield is one of the most curious
franchises in hollywood with just a few
seemingly disjointed movies and a short
manga comic to its name so what's the
story behind these stories and just how
did the franchise come to be this is the
untold truth of the cloverfield
franchise
jj abrams has built his career on
echoing genre movies of the past so it
probably won't come as a surprise to
find that he thought up cloverfield as a
way of paying tribute to classic kaiju
movies however the circumstances that
informed this idea were rooted in a more
specific personal experience one that
made abrams realize the sorry status of
american made monster movies in an
interview abrams explained i got the
idea when i went to japan and saw all
these godzilla toys in the shops i
realized that america hasn't had a
monster movie to call its own not since
king kong all those years ago anyway and
thought it was time to change that from
this toy story encounter sprang a desire
that fueled the creation of not just the
original cloverfield but an entire
sprawling franchise in the process
abrams did indeed create an ultra
intense monster one that was more than
capable of standing up against cinema's
biggest beasts
one of the most evocative aspects of
cloverfield's marketing campaign was its
emphasis on the beheading of the statue
of liberty the decapitated head closed
out the film's initial teaser trailer
with a bang while a headless lady
liberty featured as the centerpiece of
cloverfield's poster by lingering on
this image cloverfield instantly crafted
an aura of fear and dread around its
plot obviously the statue of liberty is
something americans assume will always
stand in new york city when that gets
threatened by an unknown menace well
that's bound to send a chill up anyone's
spine lady liberty's decapitation was
actually inspired by the marketing
materials for a classic 1980s action
movie as cloverfield director matt
reeves told ign the inspiration came
from the poster of escape from new york
the poster had an image on it of the
head of the statue of liberty and that
image was nowhere in the movie and it's
an incredibly provocative image
the title for the original cloverfield
didn't just spring up out of thin air in
fact the project went under several
working titles before settling on its
final moniker during production
cloverfield was known by a number of
different temporary titles including
slusho chocolate outrage and cheese even
as the movie's release date approached
cloverfield had no title to speak of
with the teaser trailer only promising a
release date it was later reported that
the film might end up going by the name
wreck as it turned out this all helped
to keep the first cloverfield movie
cloaked under a veil of secrecy the
project's marketing was defined by its
cryptic nature and all that constant
speculation over the title helped keep
up that reputation cloverfield's second
trailer in november 2007 would
eventually give the movie its name while
the movie's follow-ups would further
turn cloverfield into a full-blown brand
monster movies tend to function as much
as socio-political commentary as they do
opportunities to watch huge beasts
topple buildings just look at the 1954
movie godzilla which is a clear
reflection on japan's nuclear anxiety in
the case of cloverfield director matt
reeves had a very specific idea of what
this particular monster movie captured
through the lens of found footage was
meant to say about the time in which it
was released reeves told shock till you
drop cloverfield very much speaks to the
fear and anxieties of our time how we
live our lives constantly documenting
things and putting them up on youtube
sending people videos through email we
felt it was very applicable to the way
people feel now reeves also observed how
one moment in which the lead movie's
protagonists encounter another person
filming everything was meant to remind
people that there was more happening in
the wider world of cloverfield he
continued media is so much an aspect of
our lives today that even evoking that
idea was exciting to us that there could
be different stories out there
you still filming yeah
people are going to want to know
how it all went down
while the beast itself was absent from
the vast majority of the marketing for
cloverfield the film itself does
eventually feature the creature that has
come to be dubbed clover in the film
clover only enjoys a fleeting on-screen
presence with the brevity of its
appearances meant to heighten the sense
of fear and uncertainty felt by both the
characters and the audience despite its
minimal screen time though a whole lot
of care went into this creature
particularly in figuring out which real
world animals would come to inspire it
the primary element emphasized in the
monster's behavior was terror rather
than maliciously choosing to rampage
across new york city clover was designed
to evoke wild animals such as elephants
or horses that have become terrified and
begun to run amok this lent an extra
sense of unpredictability to clover and
its actions there was no evil plan
driving it nor any complex motivation
behind all that chaos clover was simply
engaging in random fits of destruction
because above all else it was frightened
on a visual level underwater creatures
such as piranhas were channeled into the
design of the monster's face a nod to
how clover is an extraterrestrial being
that crash landed in earth's oceans
before he won an oscar for best director
for his work on lala land and even prior
to directing whiplash damien chazelle
was just another artist looking for his
big break at one point that break looked
like it might come from bad robot
productions j.j abrams and company
enlisted chazelle to write and direct
the original version of 10 cloverfield
lane then titled valencia abrams later
told empire magazine actually damien
chazelle was originally coming on as a
director as well and he was working on
the script to direct he did incredible
work with aspects of plot and character
with his draft the eventual director of
10 cloverfield lane dan trachtenberg had
nothing but positive things to say about
the features original filmmaker he later
told the q a podcast i have so many
things to thank him for because he made
whiplash i got a chance to make a movie
and he did a great job with the script
he really gifted me with so many things
when 10 cloverfield lane was in
production its cast and crew knew it
only as valencia a low budget thriller
hailing from bad robot productions
however as production went on something
changed before long valencia had become
a spiritual sequel to cloverfield and
the title was altered to 10 cloverfield
lane
crazy
is building your ark after the flood has
already come
rather than being the result of some
brilliant plan kept secret by everyone
involved in the film however attaching
this project to the name cloverfield was
actually a last minute switch speaking
to movie web about how this change came
about director dan trachtenberg said we
wrote an original screenplay cloverfield
was not in our mind at the time during
the development process the idea came up
that it could be in the clover verse we
were a bit surprised initially but now
when you see the movie it makes a lot of
sense in terms of tone twists turns and
the thriller aspect it was definitely
the right decision by attaching the
cloverfield name to 10 cloverfield lane
this new thriller was able to stand out
more easily in a crowded marketplace
moreover following up cloverfield with
an otherwise stand-alone project allowed
the film to function as a mostly
separate narrative rather than simply
supporting itself on cloverfield plot
points and shoutouts
for years after the original cloverfield
was released news would occasionally
come to light suggesting that a direct
follow-up was in development just a few
weeks after the original debuted
director matt reeves even told rotten
tomatoes that they were considering a
number of active concepts as to where a
follow-up might go however the busy
schedules of all those involved in the
first cloverfield and particularly jj
abrams was constantly cited as a reason
why the project wasn't moving forward
with the release of 10 cloverfield lane
abrams finally had a chance to reveal
why audiences hadn't seen another movie
set in the world of cloverfield he told
fandango we had so much fun making
cloverfield that when we were done we
felt like we were done with that movie
and there were a lot of ideas for a
follow-up a lot of things were thrown
around but we now live in that
post-godzilla post-pacific rim era where
those movies have been made so what
would we do with this in mind abrams and
company opted instead to pursue a more
spiritual sequel to the first movie and
10 cloverfield lane was born
much like 10 cloverfield lane the
cloverfield paradox wasn't always meant
to be a part of the cloverfield
franchise originally it was just a
standalone science fiction movie called
the god particle however according to
the film's writer orin uzil it wasn't
long before it became attached to an
already existing franchise uzil told
collider the cloverfield paradox was
written before 10 cloverfield lane and
the expanded cloverfield universe even
existed as a thing i don't know exactly
when it became a cloverfield movie i
think everyone just knew if it fits and
it does into that cloverfield world it
should and it can only help you zeal
emphasized that it's not easy marketing
an original movie of any kind these days
and that the god particles association
with the cloverfield name likely gave it
a fighting chance at survival
in its long journey to release the
cloverfield paradox went through a
series of reshoots that were initially
shrouded in as much secrecy as anything
else in the movie however once the
project was officially released on
netflix more details emerged about what
those reshoots had entailed apparently
they had been focused on adding a new
earthbound subplot to the movie during a
facebook q a session j.j abrams noted
that scenes in the cloverfield paradox
following michael hamilton as he
navigates the situation on earth were
not originally part of the script they
were added during these reshoots at the
behest of test screening audiences who
were curious about what was happening on
the ground during the events of the main
story which takes place in space this
subplot also helped set up the infamous
ending of the cloverfield paradox which
explicitly connects the feature to the
original cloverfield with a certain
special cameo
today a quiet place is its own mega
franchise one with a widely recognizable
brand name that can generate sizeable
box office returns with very little
effort
but once upon a time the first quiet
place was just another original horror
movie not only that but there was once a
moment where it looked like it would
even be folded into the cloverfield
franchise
screenwriter scott beck told indy wire i
guess it crossed our mind and we had
spoken to our representatives about that
possibility we were actually talking to
an executive at paramount about this
film and it felt from pitch form that
there might be a crossover luckily
paramount had other ideas beck continued
but when we finally took the final
script into paramount they saw it as a
totally different movie i think in part
because conceptually it was able to
stand on its own given his affinity for
original storytelling beck was
understandably relieved when paramount
allowed a quiet place to stand on its
own two legs and of course in an ironic
twist the finished movie became so
popular that it spawned a whole new
franchise one entirely distinct from the
cloverfield name and arguably more
successful too check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you